foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome welcome
as people are making their way in and
finding their seeds you guys I'm so
impressed you were here early
[Music]
five in the morning on a Sunday
and we are making history
this morning because this is our first
ever 8 A.M service on an Easter yeah
foreign
kiddos I think all of you know but there
will be an egg hunt after the service
so I will be giving instructions on that
at the end of the service
it will be yeah
[Music]
yeah
um
[Music]
so good to see all of you
all right
so we'll give instructions on the egg
hunt and a couple other things at the
end of the service but let's
let's go ahead and Dive Right In
um
Happy Easter
let's take a moment before we get into
worship just to Center ourselves
you're here you made it let's be
completely present for this morning
so go ahead and close your eyes
take a deep breath in
exhale
one more deep breath in
foreign
think of a moment when someone that you
least expected to see suddenly stands
before you
a moment when something you've lost is
found again
and you can hardly believe your eyes
think of a moment when your fear was
suddenly proved unfounded and you were
surprised by Joy
this morning is such a moment
we resign ourselves to the worst
and then suddenly life turns around
so come this Easter morning to be shaken
from your conviction that nothing can
change your situation
come if you look at the world and feel
overwhelmed by its chaos or
disillusioned by its promises
on this morning we remember how Mary
went to anoint a corpse and was greeted
by a savior
come to worship prepare to see your life
in the world through new eyes
for Christ is risen
he has risen indeed amen
[Music]
if you've been with us through any of
the lint season you guys know that it's
always a journey getting to Eastern so
we had Ash Wednesday we had the season
of Lent we had Good Friday
and it's a journey that really takes us
through some honest questions some
sobering truths
um some of the pain and loss and even
death before we finally arrive at this
day where we come together and celebrate
New Life where we celebrate the hope of
Resurrection where we celebrate a light
that breaks through Darkness
and so as we get into our worship this
morning I just want us to take this
moment to pause and think about your own
journey and think about the Journey of
Jesus and where we've come from where we
started that led us to now in this
moment where you can have the
opportunity to grab onto New Life
[Music]
so let's just take a moment as we begin
to like Karen said take a breath and
remember where you came from and how you
arrived here
[Music]
this does not reach us we look for light
but all is Darkness
brightness but we walked in Deep Shadows
and he replies I will lead the blind by
ways they have not known
along unfamiliar paths I will guide them
I will turn their Darkness into light
and make the rough places smooth
I will not forsake them
the light shines in the darkness and the
Darkness has not overcome it
[Music]
thank you
the cross has the final words
the cross has the final
[Music]
one
sorrow makes
[Music]
the darkest night but the cross has the
fire
works
the cross has
[Music]
the
final word
evil may put a bit strong is fine but
the cross has the fine words
[Music]
by the way
the cross
[Music]
he traded for
before
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing stronger
nothing higher
nothing
[Music]
the cross
[Applause]
[Music]
the Savior has come
the cross
[Music]
the people walking in darkness have seen
a great light
on those living in the land of deep
Darkness a light has dawned
Jesus spoke again to the people and said
I am the light of the world
whoever follows me will never walk in
darkness but will have the light of life
[Music]
peace
storms surrounding me Let It Be
[Music]
at your name still a core the sea to
still the Raging me to still every way
at your name
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness
Jesus
[Music]
your silence
fear
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
Jesus Jesus
Jesus
[Music]
Jesus Jesus
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
your name is
[Music]
Jesus
Jesus Jesus
[Music]
Jesus
make the darkness tremble Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness Jesus
[Music]
free
with the blood and keep it shining let
it break into the darkness all the love
gives us to see we'll all be free
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll be free
free
[Music]
we'll be free
we will only
[Music]
get it Shining
[Applause]
let it break into the darkness all the
love tells us to see we'll all be free
yeah
[Music]
we'll all be
foreign
yes CAD we celebrate today Freedom over
the grave
Freedom over Darkness
over death
and God whatever it is in our life that
we're facing we believe that you have
come with your light and your
forgiveness and your hope
you have come to set us free
so God we celebrate that and we enter
into that today
and would we give it away to others God
the same love and forgiveness that you
have offered so freely to us
thank you Jesus it's in your name we
pray all these things
would you guys turn to the people around
you say good morning happy Easter and
then Brett will get us started on our
message
well
he is risen
happy Easter it is so good to be with
you all uh you're here you made it
so early I remember the first time we
made the announcement that our Easter
service is going to be at 8 A.M the
collective grown from the people there
that day was hilarious but um I am I'm
just yeah I'm glad that you're here and
I hope you feel
um I don't know just at least a no
matter what you're going through you
know I know we come into spaces like
this and even days like this in all
sorts of places for some of you you are
already in a place of joy and so this
just doubles your joy you know and for
others though not so much and there can
be some conflict and some kind of like
oh I should feel a thing you know
um I just want to just name like you can
just be where you are this morning and
yes there's something about choosing joy
and saying you know Hallelujah and
praise God but even in the midst of that
like there's it's not about being fake
though you know so
um I'll have to say be free be free to
be where you are and
um to well and I do hope my prayer would
be that some Joy uh would find you this
sister so um it is a joy to just be with
you and to welcome all of you that
includes those joining us online love
y'all lots you're not forgotten and
especially anyone here who's new
um today thank you so much for for being
here my name is Brett uh and I'm the
pastor here at the table
um so let's see our the title of my
Easter message this morning is your life
is not a tragedy
some of you are like I disagree Brett
um hopefully I'll convince you
um you know I could be I want to I'm
going to start with a little bit of like
um kind of cultural analysis and I
promise kids it won't go like super long
but I know they're like we want to get
to that Easter egg hunt
um so let me start with a little
cultural analysis would you agree this
is Maybe maybe the kids are tracking
this we're probably not so much but this
is mainly for like you know teens and on
up
um would you agree that the overall mood
in our culture right now
is not one of uh we might call a buoyant
optimism
but you've generally agree with that
like it's really not there's just not a
sense of like oh my gosh like maybe I
don't know I'm thinking like 100 years
ago I've heard from books I've read that
there was like a real sense of like oh
man this is gonna be great we're like on
the way to Utopia you know
um
it's different right there's just not a
sense now of like every day and in every
way things are getting better and better
you know what I mean like that's just
it's just not the vibe and um no there's
lots of analysis as to why that is right
we could be like I don't know it's
covered the coveted doldrums were still
coming out of the code
um it could be like it's uh it's it's
chat GPT
the rise of AI we're all freaking out
like technology you know or uh I mean
there's an ulcer right there's like it's
addiction we're all like addicted to
like three things it's uh it's it's
consumerism we're all just chasing that
Almighty dollar all the time we'll be
like we don't even know our neighbors
anymore you know uh and and so on and so
forth lots of you know analysis of
what's going on here but uh the question
I want to ask this morning is what if
all of those things that and like 100 of
the things we could name
those are not the sickness what if those
are symptoms
of the sickness
because you see what I want to contend
is that
um there's there's something it is
cultural largely like what's been
influencing this kind of this mood this
uh in a way subtle in ways not so subtle
cultural depression that has descended
upon many of us
um at some level kind of all of us
um it's it's
um it's a problem I think of of the
human Spirit of the human soul
um but not just an individual way like
you know it's your fault you know uh and
not in that sense more like
um
Something's Happened in the broader
culture where for I won't get like too
nerdy and historical here but for the
last few hundred years
um we have privileged the outer and the
external in the sense of um what we
could see
um what we could touch what we could
analyze what we could um say like put in
a test tube and experiment on we said uh
those things are real
that's reality and anything else
was sort of questionable you know
because if it could not be seen measured
analyzed experimented on we said now
that's not real and it doesn't matter
and so we just need to know that's
Superstition just let it all go
and uh what what happened when we did
that I would contend all of the most
important things for the human soul and
spirit went out the door I mean
everything from uh like it starts with
sort of God
you know where that's well I can't
experiment on God you know and so all of
a sudden that's now and then what what
happens
um out the door went religious belief
including our Christian faith
um out the door we kind of went our just
even our capacity to like sense to um
what you might say discern spiritually
like there's something so beautiful for
example when you look into the eye of
someone you love and seeing them not
just as like oh what an interesting
object
right but no but like to see them as as
not just in it but a but a vow as
someone holy as created not an accident
not an animal
but someone holy and precious and and
loved and they suddenly become a it's
like an icon a portal to God
or a walk in the forest is not just a
random like oh interesting nature but it
becomes creation
portal to God to God where you might
even find yourself singing a song to God
or saying a prayer
can you see how in the modern world we
have begun to lose this now we're trying
to hang on in a lot of ways right I'm
not saying it's completely gone
um but largely it just seems as every
year passes we keep letting go of these
things uh and the there's a theologian
with a very funny name but he's a very
serious Theologian his name was Hans erz
Von Balthazar that's quite a name right
I wish I my name was hanzar
um so he said he kind of charted this
trajectory and he said at first we lost
God and we're kind of let go of God and
then we lost the sense of the Sacred and
the holy and then
we lost a feel for the beautiful and
then we scoffed at the notion of Truth
and then we struggled to articulate what
was good
and then we found we couldn't really
pray anymore
and eventually he said our culture will
find itself unable even to love
I think this is the root of our cultural
depression
we've let go of of all of the most
important things
and so friends this morning I want to
invite you
to
um to re-enchant the world
to to trust that God
is
that God is
that that from The God Who is love you
have come
and to The God Who is love you will
return
and so I want to invite you this morning
to hear again the story and to trust
that's a key word which in this modern
secular skeptical age we don't do a lot
of trust in you know especially of the
church but I want to invite you to trust
again
the story so I'm gonna I'm gonna read
this is from First Corinthians chapter
15.
and um this is the one of the earliest
known discussions of the resurrection
and the Apostle Paul I love how sort of
humdrum he begins this passage
um he he says this for what I received I
passed on to you as a first importance
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures that he was buried
that he was raised on the third day
according to the scriptures
that he appeared to Peter and then to
the twelve
after that he appeared to more than 500
of the brothers and sisters at the same
time most of whom are still living
though some have fallen asleep which is
a metaphor there for death so you can
kind of hear can you hear how
unexcitable Paul is and all that like
that's he's not in a second he'll get
like more poetic and kind of energized
um but for now he's just very just very
matter of fact like hey I mean sure you
can you know ask questions or like I
don't know about this or you know
whatever but just know he's saying like
who could we saw him hundreds of other
people saw him uh I don't know just this
is how it went down you know you know
it's very kind of matter of fact but
then he makes a turn and it's a turn
that that I believe we as um as as kind
of modern people
um it's a term that we need it's a truth
that we need to be reminded of and what
he says is that the resurrection of
Christ isn't only about
Christ
and this is key for us because it's we
don't want to just come here on this day
and be like Yay Jesus
he's so great right kids he's great you
know but then it just becomes about
Jesus it's like well good for him you
know
um that's not that's not the Christian
message it's not simply yay for Christ
that it's deeper and it involves all of
us this is verse 51 towards the end of
the same chapter he says listen
I tell you a mystery
we will not all sleep but we will all be
changed in a flash in the twinkling of
an eye at the last trumpet for the
trumpet will sound and the dead will be
raised imperishable and we will be
changed
for the perishable in other words that
which passes away our physical body
must clothe itself with the imperishable
in other words a a spiritual resurrected
body and the Mortal with immortality
when the perishable has been clothed
with the imperishable and the Mortal
with immortality then the saying that is
written will come true death has been
swallowed up in Victory
where o death is your Victory where o
death is your thing for the sting of
death is sin and the power of sin is the
law but thanks be to God he gives us the
victory through our Lord Jesus Christ
can I get an amen friends this is one
reason that that I think a a skeptical
kind of more
um cynical approach
to Christian faith it just it just isn't
working it's because in so many ways we
um determine the goodness
of a story including our own story
by its ending you ever watched a movie
and it was like pretty good but then the
ending was terrible and you're like uh
I hated that you know or vice versa like
you watch a film and it's sort of
challenging it's kind of like oh gosh
okay I got this I got you know it's like
emotionally it's requiring a lot of you
and it's kind of sad but then the ending
is what
beautiful
restorative and you say oh my gosh I
loved that right have you ever had that
moment like and and so what happens in
our own life
when in the midst of yes there's Beauty
and joy but also a lot of suffering but
then we start to imagine where things
are headed our own end and in a secular
age the end is just the grave
right everyone you and everyone you love
turns to Dustin ashes and uh you're
utterly forgotten in like 100 years
that's it you're like that's the story
uh can you see how it's no wonder that
we begin to perceive our own lives as a
tragedy
but but here's the truth of the Gospel
the good news of Jesus Christ could not
be more different from that and here's
the truth your story does not end in
tragedy your story ends in Resurrection
Life
that's your story
that's your story and that's the story
our world so desperately needs because
we need to re-discover the Living God we
need to ReDiscover Beauty and truth and
goodness in a world on fire with the
love of God not just nature but creation
like this is what we must ReDiscover
again can you hear where that's
different than well Jesus was
resurrected and hooray for him
right can you hear where the that's the
message is bigger than that the message
includes you includes me includes us
your story is not a tragedy your story
is Resurrection Life I'm all worked out
this morning because it's Easter hooray
now now having said this I I realized
like in so many ways I was some of You
Were Here for a Good Friday service
which is a very different service than
this
you know solemn
serious you know
um and and there's a purpose to that the
reason uh is because that's so much of
our experience of the world
in so many ways we still live in a good
Friday kind of World
um so many crosses being built so to
speak so much suffering
and and so because of this many of you
this morning and people you love
are in the midst of suffering
um I I know so many stories here we have
folks um dealing with cancer
um struggling with job loss
suffering from an intense loneliness
from
depression
even folks are are struggling with the
results of generations
of abuse and neglect in their family
history and they're trying to do better
for their own kids trying desperately
but it can be so hard
and and so what are we tempted to do
with whatever kind of um struggles and
kind of Good Friday cross-like moments
we're going through what are we tempted
to say we're very tempted to think like
oh my God this is it like this is my my
story my story is a tragedy
thing after that no dear one your story
is not a tragedy
your story is Resurrection Life
your story is hope your story is love
your story is renewal and New Creation
at the end of all things God will one
day wipe all tears from All Eyes
at the final healing of all things
in what a day that will be because right
now our world is groaning for it as
Romans talks about groaning for
Resurrection
I had a friend
and it was when I was very young I I
honestly just have you know if you have
memories when you're like
6789 at least for those of us who are
older in years now some of the six seven
eight nine year olds are like no I have
all my memories very clearly
um but you know instead I'm 38 so this
30 years ago so my eight-year-old
memories and if I had a friend back then
his name was Joshua and he had a very
severe physical mental developmental
disabilities and I because I was so
young I don't know the details or if it
was like a particular illness or I just
remember he was that way from birth but
his mother wanted him to have like
somewhat of a you know a normal
childhood so she she wanted to make sure
he had friends and so my mom would bring
my brother and I over to his house
um to play with him it was a very good
experience for me as a young kid because
you know to to interact
um to learn to love someone who was
different than me and I remember he was
like so sweet even for all that he was
going through he would kind of do in
like in his own way kind of small he
couldn't speak
um he was you know bound to a wheelchair
although they would lay him down the
floor so he could play with him
um and but I remember it was like one of
my first experiences of seeing someone
in the midst of such intense suffering
though
uh and and so my memory that I have
is actually somewhat in a way it's sad
though you'll see how it's tinged with
with beauty and joy too my memory my
last memory of him is at his funeral
he he passed away he must have been I
don't know you know 10 or 9 or something
it was a few years later
and
um we went to that funeral and
I'll remember I remember though this
moment someone sang a song at the
funeral and I'm probably butcher it
because I was like eight and I just all
I remember is like this
um this one
little
um this one little part
which
um
basically described the way
that um
at the final healing
we will
be restored to Union with God
and the song it just speaks the line I
remember went like this Home Free
eventually
at the ultimate healing we will be home
free
Home Free
I've Got a Feeling
that at the ultimate healing we will be
home free
you see it would be easy to think that
Joshua's life was a tragedy
but can you see
that it's not
because his end is not the grave
his end
is Resurrection Life
in what was true for Joshua
will one day be true for each and every
single one of us we too will be home
free
see your story is not a tragedy
your story is the Resurrection Life and
Light
that's your story
and this is why Paul closes the chapter
with these words he says therefore my
dear brothers and sisters stand firm let
nothing move you always give yourselves
fully to the work of the Lord because
you know that your labor in the Lord is
not in vain it's the enclosing what what
this name's for us is that our world
needs a resurrection life people I mean
in light of everything I've shared right
like we need a rep people who not only
believe it like intellectually like oh
good for Jesus not more than that right
but but who say my end my my goal is is
ultimately Divine Union with God and
what does that do that changes how I
live today
because suddenly I don't have to be in
this like anxious grasping mode
right well this is my time is running
out you ever felt like that like my
times my time's running out I haven't
done everything I need to I haven't
accomplished I haven't you know okay
that's that's an anxiety that comes when
we lose sight that we are Eternal beings
and so the invitation this morning is to
be the place where Resurrection happens
even here and now the people of of great
love be people who have time to serve
time to listen
time to even enjoy the beauty around us
the people around us because we're not
eaten up with anxiety and fear about the
end but we trust
we trust that what God has done for
Jesus Christ he will one day do for
every single one of us
will you bow your heads and close your
eyes
you know maybe you walk through those
doors today
I'm not really sure
if you believed
anymore in God
in Christ in Resurrection
but now something in you longs to
believe
or maybe you've just been very distant
for quite some time kind of going
through the motions of your faith but
but distant from church distant from
Christ
and and you just sense it's time to
reconnect yourself
if either of those describes you I want
to invite you to pray this prayer and
the quietness of your own heart and mind
Lord Jesus
thank you that my life is not a tragedy
thank you that my future and All
Creations future
is resurrection
forgive me for my sin
forgive me for my cynicism
my Hardness of Heart
receive me into your family of love
may my faith Never Be Shaken
in the name of the father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen
if you prayed that prayer this morning I
encourage you not to leave this place
without telling someone
and whether it's a friend or me we also
at the world's tiniest table in that
hallway we have a little box with some
cards that you could fill out and just
let us know because we'd love to just be
in touch with you and um and encourage
you and and even if that prayer wasn't
like exactly for you I hope you've taken
encouragement and Hope from from this
morning in that message so I want to
transition us to uh to something I think
it'll be a really special time so like
Mindy mentioned earlier that we we're
now wrapping up the season of Lent lent
begins with Ash Wednesday
uh which if you were here for that
service you know we all come forward and
uh we make the sign of the cross in dust
and Ashes on your forehead and some
traditions they even say from dust you
came to dust you return when they put on
those ashes but it seemed just
completely
um right that on this morning we would
again make the sign of the cross upon
you but this morning not with dust and
Ashes
but instead
with
lavender oil to represent Resurrection
because your end is not the grave
your end is Resurrection Life and
so um in just a moment Daryl and Jeffrey
to come forward and we'll just kind of
dismiss row by row obviously there's no
pressure If you'd rather not come
forward
um you don't have to but obviously we'd
we'd love to encourage you to do that if
you um video up for it so all you have
to do is just come forward and I'll just
make the sign of the cross and speak a
word over you all and then we'll close
out with our with our final song so uh
Daryl come on forward
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
would you guys stand with us as we close
out with this last song
remembering that he has made a way for
us and we are never alone
if there's a Grace when the heart is
undefire
another way when the walls are closing
in
[Music]
and when I look at the space between
where I used to be in this Reckoning
I know I will never be
long
there is another in the fire
standing next to me
is another in the waters
Waters holding back the Seas
should I ever need remaining
how I've been set free
across the beds
[Music]
anymore
either way I won't bow to the things
[Music]
and
should I ever need reminding
me power Set Me Free and there's a grave
that holds
[Applause]
in me there is another
[Music]
one
oh there is
a fire
[Music]
in the Darkness
stands between us
[Music]
foreign
another in the fire
standing next to me will be another in
the waters
[Music]
[Applause]
that's where you'll be
like I can see the light in the Darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
standing next to me
be another in the water
[Music]
[Applause]
is
I'll count the joy come every battle
cause I know that's where you'll be
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for being here I hope
that the service in some way just
blessed your heart and give you a little
something to keep you going this coming
week as a reminder we don't normally
have 8 AM services so if you're visiting
with us we would love to see you back
here next Sunday at 5 00 PM right here 5
p.m
um also a huge thank you to Kelly and
Rebecca and Becky for setting up the
beautiful food spread over there great
job
and if you did not get a chance to
partake you will have a little while
after the service to do that so it's
just through that exit door
um right over there uh there are chicken
biscuits uh there's coffee there's
Donuts so please swing by there on your
way out
all right Kids Egg Hunt instructions
yeah it's it's just about time
um so after after I dismiss everybody
our kindergarten and younger kids will
go right inside the preschool room okay
kindergarten younger you'll go inside
the preschool room the rest of you that
are first grade and up you'll line up
right outside the door to the preschool
room and then you'll get further
instructions from there all right got it
you guys are good you guys are good
um all right I think that's it if you
are not already standing if you feel so
comfortable standing you're comfortable
standing up
um I would like to leave you with a
blessing for the road for this Easter
you like you can hold out your hands
um
I hope you take these words take Brett's
message take the music that you heard
today and take it out into your world
this coming week
turn around and believe that the good
news that we are loved is better than we
ever dared hope
and that to believe in that good news to
live out of it and toward it to be in
love with that good news is of all glad
things in this world the gladdest thing
of all
happy Easter be blessed we hope to see
you back here next Sunday 5 P.M
[Music]
things
foreign
[Music]